So in the next few minutes I'm going to
give you a complete crash course on how
futures work. Now the first thing is
futures are not like your normal stocks
and buying shares. You can buy a share
of let's say Microsoft and it will go up
or down over time and you'll make or
lose money but you can hold that share
for as long as the company exists. But
with futures you buy something called a
contract. And this contract will expire
once every either month or even 3 months
depending on what kind of asset you're
trading. And this contract's value is
tied to the physical asset. So let's say
for something like gold futures, as gold
goes up or down, your futures contract
on gold will also go up or down in
value, but usually it'll be a lot more
than the price movement of gold. So what
this allows you to do is get a lot of
leverage on that specific asset. So for
example with gold is you are essentially
buying a contract saying that I will buy
let's say 100 ounces of gold at this
current price in the future. And once
that contract is used or expires you
have that ability to do that. But in
practicality sense, nobody really ever
does that. At least for you know retail
traders like you and me. What people do
is they just buy and sell the contracts
and get the dollar value increase or
decrease of the contract and essentially
trade using that. It essentially allows
you to day trade with a very high
leverage and able to capture up and down
moves just like trading shares. Now, to
get control of these assets, you have to
put up collateral. It's called margin.
And essentially, what you're doing is
you have, let's say, $500 taken out of
your account to get control over one
gold futures contract. Now, this margin
can depend on either what asset you're
trading, how volatile the market is, or
if it's during normal stock market
hours, which is called intraday margin,
or overnight margin, which is outside of
normal stock market hours. Intraday
margin is usually extremely low because
the volatility and risk is a lot less
but overnight margin is a lot more where
you lose a lot more of that leverage
potential and it can take up to 10 times
the intraday margin to get control over
that asset. Now you also have something
called the micro futures and all they
are is they are a micro tiny asset of
the larger normal futures contract. So,
if a gold futures contract takes you
$500 worth of margin, the micro gold
futures contract takes $50 worth of
margin. So, you can essentially trade a
very small account. And what this allows
you to do is start with a small account
and grow it at a normal pace. You don't
have to be risking a huge amount of
money when you first start out trading.
You can trade micro futures and risk 20
or $30 in one trade. Now, there
definitely are risks when it comes to
trading futures. The margin isn't your
max loss on a futures contract.
Technically, you can lose more than that
if the market moves very quickly against
you, especially if you hold it through
the close, but really in reality, I
haven't really seen that ever happen.
The way to avoid that is a stop-loss
always in place when you're in a trade.
And most of the time, your futures
brokerage will close you out before your
account goes negative and you start to
lose a crazy amount of money. Now, the
most confusing thing with futures is the
price movement and how it's calculated.
Every futures contract is slightly
different. The minimum price movement is
called a tick. So if you think about
with shares, every stock like our share
of Microsoft, it can move up or down one
penny at the smallest amount of movement
most of the time because it's based on
the dollar. Now a lot of futures are not
based on a dollar. With gold, it
technically is, but something like the
S&P 500 futures, if it goes up a
numerical value of one, that doesn't
mean the index increases by $1 value.
But instead, one numerical jump is
called one point. And then the smallest
movement possible, at least for the S&P
500 futures, is 0.25. And this is called
a tick. A tick is the smallest price
movement in the futures market that
you're looking at. For oil, a tick is
0.01. And each tick is valued
differently. [music]
So for oil, if you're trading the normal
tick size, the not the micro futures of
oil, each tick or 0.01 01 worth of
movement is worth $10. [music] For the
S&P 500 futures, each tick is 0.25 worth
of movement and it's worth $1,250. And
then the micro versions of those are
just a tenth of the size. And so you can
see where the value and the movement of
each chart is way different. Now, the
cool thing about futures in the US, 60%
of your profits count as long-term
capital gains and 40% count as
short-term. And so, that's a huge tax
reduction for long-term use of futures
compared to trading other assets. Now,
for best trading platform, I highly
recommend Ninja Trader. I've used them
for over five, six years at this point.
They're a futures focused trading
platform and they're extremely powerful
and easy to execute your futures trades
on. You can check it out in a link in
description or this QR code. Now, if you
want a complete walkthrough of how I
read and day trade futures charts, check
out this video right here.